bell média annoncé hier que son service
de diffusion en continu crise sera
offert en français
l'entreprise espère rivaliser avec
netflix amazon prime vidéo disney plus
la liste des services s'allonger le
choix de programmation et de plus en
plus vaste on parle d'une véritable
guerre des plateformes de diffusion en
continu avec nous catalina briceno de
l'école des médias à l'uqam bonsoir
bonsoir
qu'est ce qui va nous arriver à réviser
aux consommateurs à qui on offre de plus
en plus choix oui alors ça se
complexifie oui les utilisateurs n'y a
pas de doute que ça va présente des
défis d'abord faut s'y retrouver dans
toute cette offre de contenu on parle de
milliers et de milliers d'heures de
contenus qui sont offerts et on a de la
difficulté maintenant à déterminer quoi
regarder à quel endroit
sans compter que les catalogues bouge et
des ménages alors par exemple dans la
l'annnonce de kraft heavy bell média
nous rappelle également que son entente
avec tou.tv extra par exemple sur
lesquels il diffusait une partie de leur
catalogue se terminer en décembre alors
ils rapatrient leurs catalogues
ce que dessiner au fait d'ailleurs avec
tous ces catalogues pixar marvel qui les
a enlevés de netflix qui les a
rapatriées sur sa propre plateforme
alors bon d'un côté il faut s'y
retrouver ensuite il y aura des choix à
faire pour les utilisateurs qui devront
gérer différents types de budgets le
premier budget évidemment c'est dans
l'ensemble de l'offre médiatique parce
que là on parle d'autres vidéos mais on
voudra également s'abonner à des
services en ligne pour la musique on
voudrait s'abonner à des journaux on
voudrait s'abonner à des plateformes de
jeux en ligne par exemple comme google
stadia ou apple arcade
alors tout ça implique qu'il va nous
falloir faire des arbitrages
les gens auront donc à faire des choix
importants de ce côté là mais je vous
dirais qu'au delà de problèmes du budget
d'argent il y aussi un budget de temps
limité et d'attention qui se fragmente
de plus en plus du côté de l'utilisateur
qui est de plus en plus sollicités donc
pour consommer cette quantité immense de
contenu alors voyez vous c'est pas tant
une question de prix parce que dans les
faits on n'a jamais payé
si peu objectivement les grilles les
prix n'ont objectivement et toutes
proportions gardées on n'a jamais payé
si peu pour une si grande quantité de
contenu jeu impressionnant coûte plus
cher mais écoutez sur netflix m'abonne à
amazon je m'abonne à tou.tv a illico
dans l'agrégation oui mais en même temps
vous conservez pour la plupart d'entre
nous 79 % des québécois selon le cefrio
encore aussi vos services de
télédistribution de serre vision de
services télévisuels en plus en plus par
contre pensez y vous rappelez vous moi
par exemple je suis mère de famille
quand je voulais lui louer un film de
n'être pas notre experte de décider par
exemple je n'ai aucune vidéo
cette belle époque ça me coûtait 4 99
pour 24 heures
si je le ramenait en retard ça me
coûtait beaucoup plus cher ensuite je
pouvais loué en ligne une location
limité de 48 heures sur des plateformes
transactionnelles comme itunes ou google
plaît ça me coûtait pour 48 heures
encore là entre 4,99 6,99 pour un titre
aujourd'hui pour 8,99 j'accède à la
totalité du catalogue de manière et
limites puisque vous nous dites c'est
que dans les faits quand on compare tout
cela ça finit par coûter moins cher ça
coûte moins cher est ce qu on a une
guerre de prix dans cette guerre des
plateformes de diffusion lee hyo
absolument une guerre de prix et ya pas
de doute les utilisateurs sont très
sensibles à l'augmentation des tarifs et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont gardés si bas
les prix à l'entrée
cela étant dit donc la vraie question
économique qui se posent à cette étape
ci c'est comment feront toutes ces
plateformes wii et cette industrie du
contenu vidéo en ligne pour survivre
sachant que leurs investissements sont
massifs que ça leur coûte de plus en
plus cher parce qu'il ya une énorme
concurrence le talent coûte plus cher il
ya une envolée dans les coûts de
production il faut développer ses
plateformes technologiques extrêmement
sophistiqué donc ça coûte et ils
investissent massivement contenu
original également donc ça leur coûte
extrêmement cher avec des prix
toutes proportions gardées qui sont
ridiculement bas donc est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à ce que des plateformes
disparaissent alors la question elle est
vraiment là qu'elle se pose parce que
d'un côté comment on peut rentabiliser
donc ce type de modèle économique
alors c'est soit on va chercher des
millions d'abonnés ce qui est faisable
lorsqu'on est une immense plateforme
internationale comme netflix ou disney
c'est beaucoup plus difficile lorsqu'on
agit sur un marché local relativement
petit comme le canada l'autre
possibilité c'est de financer à travers
le profit ou les revenus qui sont créés
dans d'autres filiales du groupe des
activités non rentables comme celle de
la plate forme d'offre vidéo en ligne
alors encore lassé des grands groupes
intégrés des conglomérats médias qui
sont favorisés
si le cas par exemple de quebecor ou de
bell média mais pas par exemple le cas
de radio canada avec un tout point tv
qui ne peut pas financer nécessairement
des pertes dans cette filiale a avec des
activités générées ailleurs quelle est
la place du contenu francophone alors
moi personnellement je trouve que en ce
moment ce qu'on voit c'est une
diversification donc des joueurs et des
offres et je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose en général je ne pense pas qu
actuellement puisse prétendre qu'on a
trop de contenu francophone au canada
on était déjà et beaucoup sens plénier
assez mal servis en fait par les offres
des grandes plateformes internationales
on a souvent cité la pauvreté par
exemple des catalogues de contenu
canadien francophone sur netflix c'est
dû entre autres à nous régime en fait de
financement et de droit mais au-delà de
ce le fait demeure il y avait peu de
contenu francophone alors je trouve que
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle de voir
le francophone augmenter autant pour les
publics québécois rrq pour les
communautés francophones hors québec
catalina briceno merci beaucoup ça va
taper dessus